David, if Joe Biden doesn't run in twenty,
twenty four, does anybody other than Kamala
Harris have a shot? I think this is an interesting
question. I imagine that if Joe Biden doesn't
run for reelection and Kamala does, there will
be a challenge from the more progressive left.
But whether it is likely to succeed depends on
things that I don't think have very much to do
with Kamala Harris. Let me explain the success of
the Biden administration over the next few years
and whether Donald Trump runs in twenty twenty
four, in my mind, are the big factors that will
influence whether Kamala Harris sails into the
2024 nomination. If Joe Biden doesn't doesn't
run for reelection, that makes it very difficult
to predict this far in advance, because right now
you could say Kamala Harris would be the likely
nominee as VP. But if the Biden presidency
is a disaster and by that I mean. Public
opinion agrees overwhelmingly that the Biden
presidency has been a disaster. I think
Harris very well could be the nominee,
but she just won't win. On the other hand,
if the Biden presidency does very well.
I don't think there's any way anybody has a shot
at unseating her for the nomination if indeed she
chooses to run. So I think that if I'm Kamala
Harris, what I'm doing is taking as visible a role
as possible in the administration, certainly more
visible than she's played so far. But we're only,
what is it, five, five, six weeks in? It would
be probably a good idea for Kamala Harris to find
some area and to be seen as a leader in
that specific area. She's been doing a
lot of Biden's sidekick, which is fine. Biden
did a lot of being Obama's sidekick as well.
But eventually it would be great for her name to
be attached to something, you know, with Biden,
although, you know, we could say it didn't go as
far as we wanted, wanted it to go. A Biden was
the sort of experience with foreign diplomacy guy
and the taking on the issue of cancer and medical
research, particularly in the context of of his
son dying of brain cancer and whether that is
good or bad, having something I think will be good
for Kamala Harris, some kind of project of her own
if Trump runs in twenty twenty four. It almost
may not matter whether the Biden administration
is or isn't successful, and it may not even matter
whether Kamala Harris is or isn't the nominee,
it will again become this kind of wacky turnout
thing where it's a combination of Republicans who
dislike the Democrat more than they dislike Trump
kind of holding their noses and voting for him,
which is just a fraction of the most of them,
like Trump. But there's enough there that they
can make a difference combined with whether
people go out. People who don't really care
about politics traditionally go out and vote for
Donald Trump and it'll be less relevant whether
Kamala Harris is or isn't the nominee. So the
point is there are way too many variables right
now. Making predictions makes makes very little
sense. We should be focused on twenty to removing
the Trump and members of the House in twenty
twenty two. And Joe Biden has to start putting
things on his list of accomplishments. Covid
relief, of course, being at the absolute top